laura is with us in Los Angeles hi Lara
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
thanks for taking my call also I'm
honored to talk to you my husband and I
are recovering from our recent recession
we both lost their jobs and in our home
like two three years ago and so we've
been since then we've had to file
bankruptcy
we did it separate for different races
and and right now and since we've been
married we've had some separate accounts
all along you know for other reasons we
never see eye to eye in financial
matters but we're both you know we're
both interested in learning more about
financial piece and saving and you know
saving for a future prepares for a
future however it's been really really
difficult to get our trust back together
how long have you guys been married
we've been married 14 years and it has
given us peace of mind not to fight over
this you know over the years so we've
learned to deal with it the sculptor's
called denial yeah maybe but my main
question and the reason I'm calling
because I'm I mean I'm accepting that
denial and what I don't know how to
explain how it both interested in doing
it but neither of us put our foot inside
and do it so my question is is it
possible to obtain financial peace on
our own or on my own in this case we
since we've lost their jobs in our house
really covering we both have you know
great jobs and but they're not they're
not what they used to be we make twice
less I mean half of as much as we used
to make understand well job let's say
this okay yes financial peace is
possible but you guys got some work to
do you've got some healing to do you
lost your home you lost your jobs you've
been beat up you've been scared you've
been mad and sometimes you try to claw
each other's eyes out in the middle of
that Sharon and I almost killed each
other when we went through that I used
to laugh and say she's from east to the
hills of East Tennessee frying-pan
throwing there's an Olympic event
you know I mean we we fought like cats
and dogs right but but over the years
now that was 25 years ago have we healed
yeah absolutely we've healed of a
wonderful marriage but there were times
we almost killed each other and it was
but why because we were hurting so bad
we were so scared we had no trust in
anything we did we wondered if we
stepped out on a piece of ground if it
was going to collapse under us you know
does everything we had leaned on fell
over you know what I'm talking about
right my biggest concern is and I'm not
going to push him for any of any future
on his side I see a lot of lack of
ambition you know he's not interested in
buying again of course it's rather there
may not be a lack of ambition it may be
like a hope well right and I'm already
on board too I know but he may not if
you don't don't confuse a lack of Hope
with a lack of ambition he may just be
hurting so bad and he just he's just
it's hard for him to believe again after
all the hard work and the other stuff
just got taken away right it's hard to
trust again in those situations so no I
think you've got to do it together and I
think you'll be really really glad you
did and you got to cut each other some
slack you got to not say things like I
think my husband doesn't have ambition
don't say that out loud again unless
you're ready to leave him I mean unless
you're just done but I mean you know you
guys got to say you know he's hurting he
lost his job which was some of his
identity he lost his home his castle and
he's embarrassed in front of his wife
and you feel the same way a shame and
there's guilt and I there was with us as
it sound familiar to you very so what I
would tell you to do is wrap yourself up
in each other's arms and go through
Financial Peace University and I'll pay
for it to help you get back on your feet
but you got to believe again in the
process and you got to give yourself
time for to do some of the things and
then see them start to work where you
learn to budget together and you combine
your finances and you trust and
communicated it's hard I mean there's
times that Sharon wants to buy something
she doesn't want to talk to me about it
even today there's times that I want to
do something and I don't want to discuss
it with her I'd rather just go do it
it's easier but it's really not it's
easier in the moment but it's a lot
easier to be an agreement on the long
haul and have respect and Trust and
communication and and love is flying
around everywhere in the middle of that
and so you hold on the line
Laura and Kelly's going to pick up and
I'm going to pay for you and your
husband to go back through our to go
through Financial Peace University the
only thing you have to do is you have to
promise Kelly two things one is if I
give it to you you and your husband have
to promise to attend I'm gonna give it
to you free free but you have to both
promise to attend each of the weeks one
week or one night a week for nine weeks
nine times you have to go to class and
then is all and then some day when
you're back on your feet you find a
couple who life has beat up and you pay
it for them you pay it forward at that
time so you hold on and Kelly will pick
up and we'll get you taken care of
you're going to live again this is the
Dave Ramsey show
you